the Priscilla's shallows of Madagascar
located on the cusp of a bustling trade
route it is the perfect place for an
ambush here is our gang of pirates
the Raiders going head to head with a
gang of rival players the cutthroats
victory goes to the team with the most
loot at the end of the hunt
we're knowing how to sail with the wind
is a pirate's most precious skill use
the way
to increase your speed or to position
yourself for tactical advantage in
battle to reap the most rewards it is
best to split up some going inland
others keeping to the open sea
[Music]
each warship has unique strengths the
frigates hull is reinforced its arsenal
equipped with numerous culverin cannons
the Brigantine is devastating up close
with a battering ram designed to break
any resistance the sloop-of-war kills
from afar with its crippling long-ranged
mortars and precise long nine cannons
flying hostile colors ride the wind all
hands on deck
position back open fire nothing will
save you now
love you soggy nutmeg don't let
bloodlust cloud your purpose you're here
for the loot and so are your rivals
store the goods then back to your
stations the team that escapes with the
most loot claims victory
searching for more targets on the
horizon our sloop-of-war spots a rival
pirate ship further inland
with its heavily reinforced hull our
frigate swoops in to save the day
bearing the brunt of the damage
another day and there's our victim
merci vamos con todo our gang of pirates
is now taking aim at the frigate and it
will take team coordination to take her
down
they're killing protect us sir with the
enemy ships broadside now vulnerable our
frigate rushes into border No
taste the blackened silver Betsy's lots
of fish piss
we've got fire against Iraklis
pirate hunters have been sent in
signaling the end of the hunt they
target the Pirates with the most stolen
loot time to make our Eastern captain or
we are good news
Full Tilt filled out all tilt the pirate
hunter defences are so strong that the
only option is escape the Brigantine is
sacrificing herself to buy time for the
frigate who carries the most loot
the frigate now needs to make its escape
through the reefs
successful pirates know when to run with
their hulls full and the wind at their
backs
[Applause]
the drunken sailor what will we do with
the drunken sailor
you